[Applause]
stick around to the end of the show
because today guess what day it is rossi
my favorite day pop quiz yes
[Applause]
that's right i do love pop quiz one
lucky audience member is going to be in
the hot seat we'll ask you three
questions about today's show and if you
get it right you get a thousand dollars
all right so pay attention
welcome back it is time for another pop
quiz
[Applause]
all right where is audience member
latavia young
hi hi
by the way i was staring at you earlier
what is this outfit with these green
boots and hello to
you um
all right latavia if you answer all
three questions correctly um with
today's show you're gonna win a thousand
dollars oh my god are you ready i am
ready okay all right all right the first
question is judd apatow joked that he'd
watch his daughter mod apatow's show
euphoria after he's done watching this
other show that he is currently watching
people reports that the appetizers are
you know they like to kid around with
each other and when mod recently posted
about the latest episode of euphoria
here's what judd replied her dad said
i'll watch it right after i finish
yellowstone
oh god
okay okay come on let it look 50 times
oh my gosh
yellowstone
oh my god
all right here's your second question
insider says we should retire what
wedding term we're talking about the
wedding term that some experts say we
have to retire anyone ever heard of the
term bridezilla oh my god bridezilla
yeah i know that one i knew that one yes
all right that means you have two
questions right you just need the final
question for a thousand dollars all
right
okay drew okay
final question name a craft uh drew
sophia bush and a friend of the show leo
kelly and sarah t made together and
there you go you got a little themed
piggy bank or you put tissues in it
right i like it
you guys need piggy banks yes
[Music]